all right um let's go to
number five easy transition here from
huffington post
to teen vogue um
and you know what i was gonna read from
this but i've done too much reading
already and i can't even
the title the headline is black power
naps
is addressing systemic racism in sleep
i can't even stomach i'm sorry i was
going to read some of this
i'm sure it's pretty funny what they're
claiming is that
well it's just right there there's
systemic racism in sleep now
sleep itself is systemically racist
and they actually call for the writer of
this article uh brittany
mcnamara at some point let me see if i
at least find this part
at some point she talks about
sleep reparations that are needed
we need to have on top of regular
reparations money there also need to be
sleep preparations
i'm not sure exactly how that will work
um
you know i kind of feel like you know if
you're a black person you want to take a
nap go take a nap
i i don't think you need specific
reparations here just like anybody else
if you want to take a nap you could
probably carve out some time in the day
to do it
uh not much of a napper myself but
anyway all right i'm not even gonna
sorry i can't i can't do you can go to
teen vogue yourself and read that
article if you want to
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content